>> Greg: NOT GOING TO D.C.!
ALL RIGHT, THE BRITISH PAPER THE
DAILY TELEGRAPH ISSUED A
HUMILIATING APOLOGY ON SATURDAY
AT ADMITTING AN ARTICLE TITLED
"THE MYSTERY OF MELANIA" WAS
FULL OF FAKE NEWS ABOUT THE
FIRST LADY.
THEY TOOK IT BACK AND PAID HER
SUBSTANTIAL DAMAGES.
THERE IS NO POINT IN RECOUNTING
THE STORY'S LIES.
IT'S THE SAME STUFF YOU HEARD
MANY TIMES BEFORE, PART OF A
LARGER INDUSTRY BUILT ON UNKNOWN
SOURCES AND BITTER BUYS.
IT SHOWS YOU THE KIND OF YEAR
THE MEDIA IS HAVING, AND IT'S
ONLY BEEN THREE WEEKS.
YOU HAVE THE BUZZFEED DEBACLE,
THE COVINGTON SMEAR, LAYOFFS AT
CLICKBAIT MILLS LIKE BUZZFEED
AND "HUFFINGTON POST."
CNN MOCKED FOR PRETENDING THEY
STUMBLED ONTO RODDERS TONES
ARRESTED NOW YOU HAVE THIS
BRUTAL TELEGRAPH HUMBLING.
THESE EVENTS HAVE ONE THING IN
COMMON: ACCOUNTABILITY.
IT'S NEW AND IT'S GOOD FOR
EVERYONE, ESPECIALLY YOU BECAUSE
YOU MAY NOT KNOW HOW FALSE THE
MELANIA COVERAGES, BUT YOU CAN
BET SHE DOES.
THAT'S THE POINT.
YOU NEVER KNOW WHAT FAKE NEWS IS
UNTIL IT'S ABOUT YOU.
ASK ANYONE WHO'S EVER BEEN THE
SUBJECT OF A STORY.
UNLESS THEIR VACUOUS ACTORS
PUMPING A SOCIALLY CONSCIOUS
FILM, IT'S NEVER GOOD.
IT'S WHY LOVE HIM OR HATE HIM,
TRUMP'S WAR WITH FAKE NEWS MAKES
THE PAST TWO YEARS WORTH IT.
HIS DISRUPTION HAS EXPOSED THE
HIDDEN LEVERS AND SO MANY DARK
GUARDS FROM TRADE TO IMMIGRATION
TO COPY EDITING AND
FACT-CHECKING.
IF ONLY ONE RESULT FROM THE
TRUMP ERA IS THAT THE MEDIA
THINKS TWICE BEFORE DESTROYING
SOMEONE FOR FUN AND PROFIT, THEN
I CALL IT A WIN.
WOULDN'T YOU?
EVERYTHING A PERSON HERE HAS
BEEN THE SUBJECT OF A STORY.
HOW CLOSE WAS THE STORY TO THE
FACTS?
>> Jedediah: I WAS THE SUBJECT
OF SEVERAL BUT WHEN I LEFT A
PARTICULAR SHOW, I REMEMBER
SEEING SOMETHING IN THE DAILY
MAIL AND READING IT AND BEING
LIKE FALSE, FALSE.
80% OF IT WAS FALSE.
THEY PUT JUST ENOUGH TRUTH IN
THERE, A TINY NUGGET OF TRUTH
AND THEY COUNT ON YOU NOT DOING
ANYTHING.
I DIDN'T DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT
BECAUSE I WAS ADVISED YOU GOING
TO DRAW ATTENTION TO IT.
THE TRUTH IS YOU LET IT SIT OUT
THERE AND IT DRIVES YOU CRAZY.
YOU ARE LIKE, THIS IS NOT ME.
IT'S A FALSE PERCEPTION.
IF ANYBODY READS IT, YOU DON'T
WANT THEM TO THINK ABOUT --
>> Greg: ITS FOREVER.
TO JED'S POINT, IT'S WHY TRUMP
IS REFRESHING THAT HE'S ACTUALLY
WILLING TO CHASE THIS LIKE A DOG
AND CATCH THE CAR.
>> Jesse: WRIGHT, THIS IS LIKE
WIKIPEDIA IS MORE ACCURATE THAT
SOME OF THIS.
I THINK AMERICANS NEED TO
REALIZE SOMETHING.
JOURNALISTS ARE NOT THAT RIGHT.
THESE PEOPLE, THEY DIDN'T
GRADUATE FIRST IN THEIR CLASS
FROM HARVARD.
THEY LIVE IN SMALL APARTMENTS IN
NEW YORK AND D.C.
THEY DON'T HAVE A LOT OF MONEY.
>> Greg: MOST OF US.
[LAUGHS]
>> Jesse: THEY ARE BORING
PEOPLE AT PARTIES.
IF YOU LINE THEM UP BETWEEN
BANKERS AND ADVERTISING
EXECUTIVES AND LAWYERS, THEY
RANK DEAD LAST ON INTELLIGENCE.
THINK ABOUT IT.
THEY GET STUFF WRONG ALL THE
TIME.
>> Greg: YOU ARE THE KING OF
GENERALIZATIONS.
[LAUGHTER]
THEY CALLED THE WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENTS' DINNER NERD PROM
BECAUSE IT'S FILLED WITH
NERDS.
THEY AREN'T THAT INTELLIGENT BUT
THEY ACT SUPERIOR AND THEY HATE
DONALD TRUMP.
THEY ARE RIDDLED WITH ERRORS AND
THEIR STORIES.
ALL OF THE ERRORS MAKE
REPUBLICANS LOOK BAD.
WHY IS IT THAT THEY NEVER MAKE
MISTAKES THAT MAKE DEMOCRATS
LOOK BAD?
IT'S ALWAYS ON THE OTHER SIDE.
>> Jedediah: THEY MAKE
MISTAKES THAT MAKE THEM LOOK
GOOD.
>> Greg: JUAN, WHEN I ASKED --
IN THE BREAK, HAVE YOU BEEN THE
SUBJECT OF THE STORY AND YOU
WERE LIKE HA!
AND YOU ARE A JOURNALIST.
IT'S HAPPENED TO YOU.
>> Juan: I BETTER INFORM MY
WIFE AND A BUNCH OF PEOPLE.
[LAUGHS]
I MUST SAY THAT TO ME WHEN YOU
SEE WHAT HAPPENED WITH "THE
DAILY TELEGRAPH," APPARENTLY
MORE THAN A MILLION DOLLARS PLUS
FOR LEGAL FEES.
THEY WERE WRONG.
I MUST SAY A LOT OF THIS COMES
FROM "FIRE AND FURY."
I THINK THERE ARE SEVERAL BOOKS.
THERE'S A BOOK OUT THIS WEEK
ABOUT TRUMP.
A LOT OF THIS DOESN'T SEEM LIKE
IT'S MYTH.
A LOT OF IT COMES FROM INSIDE
THE TRUMP CAMP.
>> Jesse: THEY HAD BASIC FACTS
WRONG.
>> Juan: THERE'S A BIGGER
STORY HERE ABOUT THIS PRESIDENT.
YOU ARE SAYING TO THE AUDIENCE
JUST IGNORE EVERYTHING THAT'S
NEGATIVE ABOUT TRUMP.
>> Jesse: THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
THE MEDIA GETS SO MANY THINGS
WRONG ABOUT REPUBLICANS.
WHEN THEY DO GET SOMETHING RIGHT
IN ITS REAL NEWS, NO ONE
BELIEVES THEM.
THEY HAVE NO TRACK RECORD.
>> Juan: GO BACK AND SEE HOW
MUCH ATTENTION DONALD TRUMP GOT
FROM THE CNNS AND MSNBCS OF THE
WORLD.
LET ME SAY WHEN HE GOES AFTER
BUZZFEED FOR THEIR PROBLEMS OR
"HUFFINGTON POST" OR GOES AFTER
"THE NEW YORK POST" BECAUSE THEY
ARE LAYING OFF PEOPLE, I SAY
MAN, THAT'S LOW.
IN OTHER WORDS, YOU ARE GOING TO
HIT JOURNALISTS WERE BEING
FIRED.
>> Jesse: THOSE SAME
JOURNALISTS LOVE GETTING PEOPLE
FIRED.
THEY WANT YOU FIRED, JUAN.
THEY WANT ME FIRED.
THEY REVEL IN IT.
>> Greg: WITH
"THE HUFFINGTON POST" DOES IS
REPURPOSE ARTICLES THAT WERE
DONE -- MEDIA MATTERS PUTS OUT
SOMETHING AND THEN
"HUFFINGTON POST" PUTS IT OUT.
SCREWING OVER PEOPLE TO THE
RIGHT OF THEM AND GETTING THEM
FIRED.
I HAVE NO SYMPATHY.
I WROTE FOR "HUFFINGTON POST"
FOR TEN YEARS I THINK.
I TEND TO FORGET THAT.
IT WAS A LONG TIME.
HERE'S THE BIGGER THING, MORGAN.
IT USED TO BE RARE THAT JOE BLOW
WOULD BE A TARGET OF THE MEDIA.
BUT NOW WE ARE IN THIS AREA
WHERE ANYONE TANGENTIALLY
RELATED TO TRUMP, VOTING FOR
TRUMP, SUPPORTING TRUMP, WEARING
A RED HAT OF THE
WASHINGTON MONUMENT, NO ONE IS
SAFE.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE REALLY --
>> Morgan: THE WHOLE COVINGTON
THING, I ALMOST TWEETED, JUST
WATCHING THE VIDEO, I ALMOST
WAITED INSIDE ONE OF THESE KIDS
DOING?
I STOPPED AND I'M GLAD I DID AND
THEY WAITED A DAY AND LOOKED AT
THE NEWS.
THEN YOU SAY WAIT A MINUTE,
THERE'S A BIGGER STORY HERE.
YOU TALK ABOUT MEDIA
ACCOUNTABILITY WRIT LARGE, JUAN
IS RIGHT.
IN THE REPUBLICAN PRIMARY, IT
WAS ESTIMATED IN THE GENERAL
ELECTION IN THE 2016 CAMPAIGN
THAT TRUMP GOT PROBABLY TOO
MILLION DOLLARS IN FREE MEDIA.
I THINK WHAT'S HAPPENING --
I THINK IT'S GUILT THAT THEY
REALIZE THAT THEY LET HIM CALL
INTO THESE TV SHOWS ON A DAILY
BASIS.
THEY SHOWED -- EVERY NETWORK
SHOWN ALL OF THE RALLIES LIVE.
THEY DO THESE THINGS AND THOUGH
I THINK THESE OTHER NETWORKS AND
JOURNALISTIC OUTFITS FEEL A
LITTLE BIT OF CULPABILITY, SO
THEY HAVE OVEREXTENDED.
>> Jedediah: ANDREW BREITBART
WAS TALKING ABOUT THE WAR WITH
THE MEDIA BEFORE IT WAS COOL.
EVERYONE WAS TALKING ABOUT